how can entrepreneurs
most entrepreneurs that I know have a
hard time focusing they're terrible at
focusing because we like to think about
the big ideas we'd like to see you know
we have a vision for where we want the
world to be we have a vision for what we
want our product or service to be and
it's frustrating and it's it's
challenging doing all the small steps
the day-to-day grind to make that happen
right we like being arsonist we like
light and little fires all over the
place we don't like seeing something
through a lot of times it's most
entrepreneurs but here's the thing you
have to stay focused if you want to be
successful as an entrepreneur you have
to stay focused pick one thing too many
entrepreneurs are running with five
different business ideas and none of
them end up being amazing they all just
struggle along and are mediocre because
you can't focus can I'm gonna share with
you how I stay focused what's really
helped me develop my focus muscle is
it's something that you got to really
work on it's so easy to get distracted
this this comes as a result of a
question that came from my YouTube
viewers I am greater who said can you
talk about focus so I am greater on
YouTube this is for you here are three
things okay these three things will help
you stay focused in your business and
achieve success as an entrepreneur you
ready number one create a morning
routine that serves you okay I used to
find that when I woke up in the morning
I didn't have a lot of motivation even
if I had a great day yesterday and I was
on fire and people were seeing great
things about my business and I was
really helping somebody the next morning
I would wake up and feel like I had to
start all over again like it was hard to
get out of bed and hard to just get
going on my work so I started creating a
morning routine that really served me
and you want something that inspires you
that gets you going that you know gets
your blood pumping a little bit
that makes you get up and start going to
work start doing something when I first
got started what I was doing was I would
create a PowerPoint presentation and it
would have all of the comments that
people have left
for me at various presentations in
seminars that I was doing and it would
have emails that people left for me
seeing how much I impacted them and
helped change their lives because I got
complacent you know I got comfortable I
settled and and I just wasn't motivated
so seeing those comments from people
made me get up and and want to do more
because you want more right I wanted to
go and help more people and on that
PowerPoint I had those comments and also
had some pictures and goals for what I
wanted to accomplish so the pictures
kind of represented things that I wanted
to do in my life things that I wanted to
have happen to me so as a daily reminder
that hey but if I don't go do something
today if I don't get up and work none of
those things are gonna happen and I'm
not gonna be able to help more people so
that helped me in nearly days now what I
do I've pretty strict regimen but it's a
combination of responding to you guys so
part of the best one of the best parts
of my day is in the morning I wake up I
have my lentils for breakfast and I read
the comments that come in from you guys
on YouTube on Twitter or Facebook and I
respond then I use the morning to
respond because for the most part
they're really good comments there's
nobody right I didn't say Evan you suck
I hate you it's all good stuff usually
and that gets me going right like seeing
your comments that makes me want to make
new videos I mean like 800 something
videos you guys make me want to do more
that keeps me going so if you have any
kind of feedback coming in from your
audience fans do that in the morning the
other thing that I do that I find really
helps I do a quick workout in the
morning and it's a combination of doing
weights while I'm watching baseball
highlights and news because I love
baseball that kind of gets me going and
seen athletes pushing themselves and you
know striving to accomplish their goals
makes me want to go and push myself
harder the next thing I'll do is a quick
cardio workout will i watch youtube
videos of people who I respect look up
to inspirational speeches things that
have been recommended to me by friends
or by YouTube and that kind of gets me
pumped and gets me going I have a shower
after and in there I'll think about what
I learned what I want to go attack on
the day and so all of that combined take
some
but make sure that I'm set for the
morning so kind of the summarize what my
schedule looks like because I kind of
went all over the place I'll wake up
I'll have my breakfast and while I do
that I'll look at the social media
comments and right back to you guys from
there I'll do a quick weight workout
while watching baseball highlights and
then I'll do a cardio workout and I will
watch youtube videos that inspire me and
then I'll go have a shower and think
about everything that I've learned today
and everything that I want to accomplish
in the day and by the time I come out of
the shower I'm ready to go and I'm
excited and ready to take on the day so
that's number one the state focus create
a morning routine that serves you so you
can get out of bed and get to work okay
the second thing is chunk your time this
is one of the biggest sucks for a lot of
a lot of people okay what happens you
get to work you get to your office so
you sit down at you in your home office
whatever it is you start thinking of an
idea and then email comes in and and you
get distracted you answer that email you
figure out what you're doing and you get
back into your work more then another
email comes in and you just constantly
get get distracted and I find that
entrepreneurs are so much in reactionary
mode always putting out fires that
they're never actually proactively doing
something and building their business
it's always in reaction to something
else happening you have to control your
time okay and if you don't respect your
time and put limits on it then people
are gonna walk all over you you have to
put those boundaries in place and so it
starts with chunking and what I mean by
chunking is anything that you do
multiple times per day so say it's
checking email do once per day so email
once a day you can do it it'll change
your life
anything you do multiple times per week
do once per week anything about two
times per month do once per month chunk
it down because when you're focused on
those things you're much better at those
tasks when I'm answering email I'm much
better going through all the email
quickly handling anything needs to be
handled then if I'm trying to do a throw
today when I have my videos usually -
Wednesday afternoon is when I do my
videos I do all my videos for the week
on the Wednesday afternoon that puts me
in the mindset I know I'm waking up I'm
doing videos I'm focused on the video
the video gets better each time I do it
it's not like I do a video here video
there because the set-up time is too
much just not even just an
the camera but the mental setup time
great I have to think of it what I'm
gonna say have to get in the zone be
ready for videos the same thing happens
if I'm meeting people I meet people on a
Thursday I have my phone calls I have my
radio show I have my face-to-face
meetings I have interviews I always put
it on a Thursday and I put them back to
back to back to back to back my
Thursday's are crazy because that's my
mindset going in Thursday I wake up I
know I'm going into meeting these people
because what happens typically okay if
you're meeting people throughout the
week half an hour before a meeting comes
up you're not doing anything if you're
at your office you're working on
something and you know a meetings coming
up in half an hour you're you're not
actually working on anything because you
know you're gonna have to stop in half
an hour
to go do that interviewer or meet that
person or do that phone call so you get
distracted but if you put them back to
back to back to back to back and works
out beautifully and you carry the
momentum from one into the next on
Monday and Tuesday will be more of my
admin's
stuff that I have to work on just nose
to the grindstone don't bother me don't
talk to me I'm working hardcore if I'm
if I'm writing if I'm doing my
newsletter from doing a proposal if I'm
doing something on my website whatever
it is usually it's gonna be Monday
Tuesday okay so you chunk out your days
you chunk out your weeks you chunk out
you're months so you block time off to
focus on a specific task okay I find
that helps me so much you don't get
distracted by things coming in all the
time the last thing is don't answer your
phone okay my phone my phone number is
not on my business card I don't know the
number to my cell phone because phone
calls unscheduled phone calls are other
people's agenda for your time okay when
you answer the phone when you pick it up
you get distracted
you've immediately lost whatever you're
working on right whatever you're working
on is gone now you get distracted by
this phone call even if it's just to see
who's calling if you don't pick it up
you get distracted like I wonder what
that person wants and you lose your
focus and they get back into something
once you've started it and you've left
to get back in it takes way too much
time right it can take you 30 40 50 sick
two minutes just to get back to where
you were before it's a big waste of time
so no unscheduled phone calls okay my
phone number is on on my website it's
not on my business card I have my
Twitter account on there but not my
phone number I will do a lot of business
over the phone but it's gonna happen on
a Thursday and you're not calling me
interrupting my day now you have to be a
responsive organization and just because
I'm only checking email once a day or if
I'm only taking phone calls once a week
it doesn't mean that my organization the
people who I have on my team can't
answer email and be on the phone if
that's part of that's important to your
business but you have to get yourself
out of that equation because you're just
gonna be running around putting out
fires all day long here's the one
exception okay the one exception is when
you're in the state of flow when you're
in the state of flow that's when you're
feeling something that's when you're
really creative that's when you look
down and it's nine o'clock in the
morning and you look up and it's five
o'clock in the afternoon you have no
idea where the day way because you're
being so productive you're so focused on
that you know what I'm talking about
right you know you've been in those
moments when you're in the zone in the
flow okay when that happens you have to
run with it because the stuff that
you're gonna create when you're in that
moment is gonna be way better way more
life-changing for you and for your
customers then then if you just try to
force it into a certain chunk of time
okay creative work cannot always be
forced into a certain chunk so when it
hits you when you're feeling you have to
run with it you have to put off other
stuff because that is so critical now
don't fool yourself okay don't come and
tell me you know what I'm really feeling
these emails I'm in the flow on my email
so I'm gonna keep doing email even
though it's past my chunk time no okay
don't fool yourself be honest you have
to be really feeling the flow okay
you're not in the flow doing emails
something creative something powerful
something important that's how you stay
focused
you got a lot out of me hopefully that
helps I'm passionate about this subject
because if you don't stay focused if you
don't keep on track with what you're
doing you're not gonna accomplish
anything right you're not gonna have the
impact you're looking for you're not
gonna make the money you're trying to
make you're just gonna be bounced around
from one idea to another idea to another
idea I never actually achieve anything
so you gotta stay focused use those
tactics to help you so create a morning
routine is number one chunk your time is
number two don't answer the phone no
unscheduled phone calls is number three
and the only thing that is an exception
is when you're in the state of flow I
hope that helps believe for those of you
watching like the video please give it a
thumbs up below it makes me want to do
more for you and let me know what you
think leave a comment you have a
question leave it below I'll make a
video response thank you so much and
I'll see you soon